Katherine I did yesterday I did not
Katherine yesterday because they want
about what happened it was impossible
for me for most of the cartoonist I know
was impossible to draw how can we draw
today the things get fixed with a pencil
inside and blood pick them up that's why
I did that picture because it was only a
simple picture i was able to to make
something that something about how to to
resist him go on and still feeling alive
despite what happened and that's all
simply catalyst I think that it was
necessary to explaining talked about
sharp and cover to the people that were
killed one of them was the editor but of
course both cartoonist and inshallah
Abdul there were so many talented jatin
estas shab t news in Kabul and for some
people from a generation these persons
were very awesome great influences
because they were underway before us and
showing us where to go and when I was
young and the way when I was a young
adult single door beings in the
newspapers in Charlie already was a way
to understand ok lobbying is a way to 20
live and the ring is a way to tell into
the saliva and the contrast with
yesterday is a
is awful and we do know we had some
troubles with for inspiration of
equations of representation for fit and
it's probably linked today we do know
it's probably linked it's helpful to
consider this
04 these teachers I want her 30 today
under the game Terry Center
it should be there where optical she
should do anybody should grow but what
we want and she speak with what we want
is simple I think was it Kabir who was
in his 17 yeah yeah yeah
and Gabby was appearing on the TV show
and there was a body discovered Gabby
this way it's a bit too strange to it
worth to say okay I look at me because
of her doesn't matter but there was no
even message influence I've made from
some time some kind of big conventions
matter of course there are some great
influences because kathy was first
before being a good satirical catalyst
it was simply a good do-over but sorry
very talented and very strong sinking by
drawing and it's in keeping by being
politically engaged city by Jordan for
impact do you think that death will have
on cartoon editor in France and it is
around the world so judging from the
images that we've seen today you're not
going to be quiet you're not going to be
silenced any idea but in future but i
guess the wish about attack was to stop
shining was to disturb them to dictate
and stuff
this magazine and I hope Charlie one
step because fully some catalysis did a
lie there and I think many people today
are thinking what a way to go and with
Charlotte what can we do today with
shoddy shoddy doesn't have to stop with
the shoddy stop her we cannot surrender